♪ (intro music) ♪
Modern apps are highly asynchronous.
Anything can happen
at any time, in any order.
You can think of these events
as streams of data.
Dart has great support
for asynchronous streams of data,
using streams.
How do you use streams in a Flutter app?
Use the StreamBuilder widget.
StreamBuilder will listen to events
flowing from the stream.
For every new event,
it will rebuild the sentence,
giving them the latest event to work with.
Start by giving StreamBuilder a stream.
Just plug it in.
Then write the builder.
Given a snapshot,
declare what should this part
of your app look like.
You can provide initial data
so that your widget has something to show
while it's waiting for the first event.
Otherwise, make sure you're checking
if the snapshot has data.
If it doesn't yet,
you can show a loading indicator.
For more granularity,
check ConnectionState.
As always, check for errors.
snapshot.hasError is your friend.
You can use StreamBuilder
with data from Firebase, sensor events,
even network connection status.
For more info on StreamBuilder
and all the other widgets,
visit flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪